[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL. FOR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO.
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
THEY'RE AWESOME GALGIANI
[inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG HILL.
HUESO --
TADA [inaudible]
JACKSON JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MORE LOCK.
BROWN [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH.
RUBIO.
SKINNER.
STERN.
STONE.
NUMBER WHITE HOUSE SKI.
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LET IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR HILL.
LOTUS CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
MOTHER TERESA SAYS.
PRAYER IS NOT ASKING.
PRAYER IS PUTTING ONESELF IN THE
HANDS OF GOD'S.
AT GOD'S DISPOSITION.
AND LISTENING FOR THAT VOICE IN
THE DEPTHS OF OUR HEARTS.
SO GRACIOUS GOD.
TODAY WE COMMIT OURSELVES TO A
STANCE OF RECEPTIVITY.
AND ATTENTIVENESS TO YOUR
PRESENCE WITHIN OUR HEARTS AMEN.
A SOLUTION TO THE A A UP.
AMERICA AND AND ONE NATION UNDER
GOD INDIVISIBLE.
YEAH ON GOOD MORNING MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO START WITH THE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
MONNING AT THE PRO TEM'S DESK
[inaudible]
IF I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS IF I COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION IT'S MY PLEASURE TODAY
TO INTRODUCE A CONSTITUENT OF
MINE.
WHO'S AN ATHLETE AN ACTRESS A
BUSINESS WOMAN AND SHE LIVES IN
SANTA CRUZ HER NAME IS BROOKE
ENDS.
MISSENSE IS VISITING THE STATE
CAPITOL AS PART OF CALIFORNIA
FITNESS WEEK.
AFTER A LIFETIME OF PLAYING
SPORTS SHE FOUND HER CALLING IN
THE SPORT OF CROSSFIT.
MISS SENSE TOOK THE SUPPORT BY
STORM IN FINISH SIXTH PLACE IN
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONALS IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN THEN IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN SHE WON FIRST PLACE IN
THE CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
COMPETITION GOING ON TO PLACE
FOURTEENTH IN THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
CROSSFIT GAMES. FOR SUCCESS IN
THE SPORT OF CROSSFIT HAS BEEN
FEATURED IN NUMEROUS
DOCUMENTARIES.
THAN TWO YEARS AGO MRS ANSYS
CAREER EXPANDED WHEN SHE WAS
CAST AS AN AMAZON WOMAN IN THE
MARVEL MOVIE WONDER WOMAN AND
ASKED TO RETURN AS AN AMAZON
WOMAN.
IN JUSTICE LEAGUE.
CAPITALIZING ON THE SUCCESS LAST
YEAR SHE LAUNCHED HER OWN A PAIR
ONLINE AND SWEAR WHICH HAS BEEN
A TREMENDOUS SUCCESS INCLUDES A
LINE OF CLOTHING.
THAT DONATES PARTS OF ITS
PROCEEDS TO A NONPROFIT FOCUSED
ON ENDING PROSTATE CANCER.
MRS INSIST SUCCESS IS A TRIBUTE
TO HER HARD WORK AND DEDICATION
TO PHYSICAL FITNESS.
AND JUST BEFORE WE WELCOME MISS
SENSE I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE WORK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CHANNING GIPSON.
WHO ARE CARING ACR FIFTEEN OF
NATIONAL FITNESS WEEK SO MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A SENATE
WELCOME FOR MISS BROOKE AND?
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
THANK YOU CENTER MONNING MEMBERS
WE ARE STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR SENATOR WILK.
SENATOR WILK AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO HONOR THE SENATE
CREE TO VALLEY SIGNAL NEWSPAPER
ON ITS ONE HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY.
RICHARD BUT MEN THE SIGNALS
PUBLISHER CHOICES TODAY IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBERS.
RICHARD AND HIS WIFE KRIS WERE
PUBLISHERS FROM 200-042-2000
SEVEN AND THEN REPORTS THE PAPER
AGAIN IN JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN UNDER THEIR
LEADERSHIP THE CIRCULATION HAS
INCREASED 10%.
AND THE PAPER REMAINS TO GO TO
NEW SOURCE FOR PEOPLE THE SENATE
CREATE A VALLEY.
IN FACT VANESSA NIGHT FIGHT
EVERY DAY ON WHO GETS TO READ
THE SIGNAL NEWSPAPER AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING
HAPPENING A KITCHENS THROUGHOUT
THE SENATE CREE TO VALLEY FOR
NOW A HUNDRED YEARS.
ON FEBRUARY SEVENTH NINETEEN
NINETEEN THE NEWSPAPER OF THE
NEW ALL SIGNAL BECAME THE WEEKLY
HOMETOWN PAPER FOR COMMUNITY OF
JUST A FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE.
COVERING TIDBITS OF A SMALL TOWN
THE CIRCULATION WAS A MERE.
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THE SINGLE
MAINTAINS A LOCAL FLAVOR TO
TODAY WITH NEWSPAPER COVERAGE
THAT FOCUSES ON ISSUES IN
ADVANCE THAT MATTER MOST TO THE
COMMUNITY. TO OUR HOME NOW OF
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
DELIVERED SIX DAYS A WEEK
INCLUDES A SUNDAY MAGAZINE
ADDITION THAT GOES TO SEVENTY
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS.
AND A WEBSITE THAT'S CHOCK FULL
OF LOCAL NEWS SPORTS COMMUNITY
STORIES PHOTOS AND VIDEOS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX THE NATIONAL
NEWSPAPER ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
NAME THE SIGNAL QUOTE THE BEST
PEOPLE FOR GENERAL EXCELLENCE IN
QUOTE FOR NEWSPAPERS WITH THE
CIRCULATION UNDER.
FIFTY THOUSAND IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN THE SIGNAL WAS
NAMED THE NUMBER ONE NEWS SOURCE
FOR LOCAL INFORMATION IN A POLL
CONDUCTED BY THE CITY OF SANTA
CLARITA.
KRISTIN RICHARD BERMAN EXAMPLE
FIVE WHAT IT WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
TRUE HAVE TO BE A TRUE COMMUNITY
NEWSPAPER.
THE PAPER SELF REFLECTS THESE
VALUES EVERY DAY IN ITS COVERAGE
OF THE SANTA CRUZ VALLEY AS WELL
AS HIS CHARITABLE WORK.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
SIGNAL DONATED MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO OVER A LOW OVER A HUNDRED
LOCAL NONPROFITS.
TRULY A PAPER AND PUBLISHERS
CARE ABOUT THE HEART AND SOUL OF
OUR COMMUNITY.
TODAY MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING THE SIGNAL.
HIS PUBLISHER RICHARD BERMAN AND
THE HUNDRED TO SIGNALS EMPLOYEES
WHO TIRES WE WORK TO DELIVER THE
NEWS TO OUR DOORSTEPS EACH AND
EVERY DAY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE FOR TWO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WHICH
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR FEBRUARY FOURTH
THROUGH THE SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY TWO AND SEVENTY THREE
WILL BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND
READING TODAY UPON BEING
REPORTED.
FROM THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE.
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS MS SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL 219-222-21220 TWO
AND SENATE BILL.
TWO TWENTY THREE THANK YOU FIRST
READING OF BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SENATE THIRD READING.
WE WILL START WITH FILE ITEM TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
MOVE TO AN ACTIVE THE DUST WILL
NOTE THANK YOU.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SENATOR
PAN.
ALL THE FIRES.
MS SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
NINE BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR CELEBRATION
CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS OUT LAST EARLIER THIS
WEEK WE CELEBRATE LUNAR NEW YEAR
THIS IS THE RESOLUTION ESSIE OUR
NINE SO I I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR ALLEN BY JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A A
BITTERSWEET CELEBRATION BECAUSE
THE THE THE THE THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR THIS YEAR IS THE YEAR OF
THE PIG.
AND SO ON BEHALF OF MY JEWISH
CAUCUS COLLEAGUES THIS DECIDEDLY
UN KOSHER ANIMAL --
WE WE STILL CELEBRATE WITH HOW
WHAT A WONDERFUL CELEBRATION
THIS IS.
OF FOOD AND AND FAMILY AND
HERITAGE HIGH IT'S A IT'S A
TREMENDOUS THING THE THE LUNAR
NEW YEAR I KNOW WORLD ME
CELEBRATING WE ARE CELEBRATED.
WITH OUR WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS --
BUT IT SO IT'S WITH A HEAVY AND
JOYFUL HEART.
THAT I ASKED MY JEWISH CAUCUS
COLLEAGUES TO CELEBRATE THIS
YEAR OF THE PAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN SENATOR
WIENER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
BAD PRESS AS A AS A JEWISH
SENATOR WHO DOES NOT KEEP KOSHER
AND WHO ALSO REPRESENTS A VERY
VERY LARGE API COMMUNITY HOW ONE
ARRIVES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS --
RESOLUTION --
AND I WANT TO KNOW THE LAST YEAR --
THE CENTER FOR SACRAMENTO AND I
I JOINT AUTHORED A BILL THANK
YOU FOR PASSING A TO DESIGNATE
LUNAR NEW YEAR IS A DAY OF
SPECIAL SIGNIFICANCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO WISH EVERYONE A
VERY VERY HAPPY NEW YEAR.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER SEE NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
VERY GOOD MISS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
AYE ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FELL [inaudible]
I FORGES.
BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I DRAWS THEM [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I DADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MOREAU.
NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
I AMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE E..
AYE WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
MORRELL.
I WAS THIRTY SIX KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING ON
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SENATOR PAN.
SIR PAN TO HAVE ANOTHER
RESOLUTION YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PASS ON FILE VERY GOOD WE HAVE
COMPLETED THE DAILY FILE.
WE WILL MOVE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR ADJOURNED
IN MEMORIES.
SENATOR JACKSON DID YOU HAVE A
JOURNEY MEMORY.
MONDAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY OTHER
ADJOURNED IN MEMORIES.
ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA ASK EVERYONE
TO JUST HANG TIGHT FOR A MINUTE
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A RESOLUTION
2% BUT WE'RE WAITING FOR OUR
GUESTS TO ARRIVE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY.
SO DON'T LEAVE WILL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOUR
WE ARE RETURNING
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR MITCHELL IS READY.
MS SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR MITCHELL RELATIVE TO
BLACK HIV AIDS AWARENESS DAY.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT AND FOR YOUR PATIENCE
COLLEAGUES TODAY.
I AM PROUD TO JOIN WITH.
MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR WIENER AND
STAND AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS BEGINNING COUNTY
COLLABORATION WITH THE LGBT Q.
CAUCUS.
THE HIGHLIGHT A CRITICAL ISSUE
FACING REALLY ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
TOGETHER TODAY WE WILL PRESENT
SR FIFTEEN RECOGNIZING FEBRUARY
SEVENTH AS NATIONAL BLACK HIV
AIDS AWARENESS DAY.
WE ALL REMEMBER THE PAINFUL PAST
IN THE EIGHTIES THE HIV AIDS
EPIDEMIC TO THIS NATION BY STORM.
CUTTING FAR TOO MANY LIVE SHORT.
AND LEAVING A VOID IN THE HEARTS
OF THOSE LEFT BEHIND.
IT WAS THE LGBT COMMUNITY THAT
SUFFERED THE BRUNT OF THESE
LOSSES.
PARTICULARLY AFRICAN AMERICANS
WITHIN THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER SINCE THE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE CONTINUED TO
WORK TIRELESSLY TO RECOVER FROM
THE PAIN AND THE BIAS OF THAT
ERA.
BUT PROGRESS QUITE FRANKLY
COLLEAGUES HAS BEEN UNEVEN.
IN MORE RECENT YEARS HIV
DIAGNOSES AMONG BLACK WOMEN HAVE
DECLINED AND AMONG BLACK CAMERA
SEXUAL MAN AS WELL.
HOWEVER THEY WERE FAR TOO MANY
YEARS WITH THOSE COMMUNITIES
WERE NOT RECOGNIZE AND TREATMENT
DOLLARS NOT DIRECTED TOWARD
THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS.
HOWEVER AMONG BLACK GAY AND
BISEXUAL MEN HIV DIAGNOSES HAVE
DECLINED MUCH AT A MUCH SLOWER
RATE.
DUE TO SYSTEMIC MARGINALIZATION.
BLACK COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO
LACK THE RESOURCES AN OUT REACH
TO HELP IN THE FIGHT AGAINST HIV.
SIMILARLY STIGMA TATIAN
STIGMATIZATION ASSOCIATED THE
ILLNESS OFTEN PRESENTS MEMBERS
OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY FROM
ACCESSING CRITICAL PROTECTIONS
AND TREATMENTS AGAINST HIV.
TO NOT ONLY KNOWLEDGE THE
DISPARATE IMPACT HIV HAS HAD ON
BLACK AND LGBT COMMUNITIES.
BUT ALSO BEGIN TO ENGAGE IN
MEASURES THAT ACTIVELY COMBAT
THESE BURDENS.
INSURING THAT HIV AIDS NO LONGER
TAKES THE LIVES OF VALUABLE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND YOU'LL HEAR FROM MY
COLLEAGUE BUT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
RISE SAYS HERE THE THE LGBT
CAUCUS -- IN
SUPPORT AND PARTNERSHIP ON THIS
RESOLUTION --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD FOR
MANY YEARS --
TO TRY TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
NEW AND AND TO TRY TO MAKE SURE --
THAT EVERYONE WHO'S LIVING WITH
HIV HAS ACCESS --
TO TREATMENT HEALTH CARE OUGHT
TO BE ABLE TO LIVE HEALTHY LONG
PRODUCTIVE LIVES --
WE MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS --
REDUCING INFECTIONS --
AND GETTING PEOPLE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE BUT UNFORTUNATELY --
DOC PROGRESS HAS NOT BEEN
EQUITABLE --
AND HAS NOT REACHED ALL MEMBERS
OF COMMUNITY OF OUR COMMUNITY --
AND PARTICULAR --
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY --
HAS EXPERIENCE HIGHER RATES OF
INFECTION --
HIGHER RATES OF LACK OF ACCESS.
TO HEALTH CARE --
AND THESE DISPARITIES.
WE NEED TO REACH TO ENSURING
THAT EYES WE ENHANCE OUR
APPROACHES TO PREVENTION THROUGH
CRAP AND OTHER POWERFUL
PREVENTION TOOLS --
AS WE IT MAKE MORE MORE PROGRESS
IN -- IN
SUPPRESSING PEOPLE'S VIRAL LOADS
AND HELPING PEOPLE LIVE.
A HEALTHY PRODUCTIVE LIVES THAT
EVERYONE CAN SHARE AND NOT
PROGRESS AND THAT EVERYONE FROM
ALL COMMUNITIES --
AND SO --
COLLEAGUES I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION AS
WE MOVE FORWARD --
TOWARD THE FEEDING --
THIS EPIDEMIC TOWARDS ENDING NEW
HIV INFECTIONS AND MAKING SURE
EVERYONE CAN BE HEALTHY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER SENATOR
BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
I STAND AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF US ARE
FIFTEEN IT WANT WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR.
MITCHELL FOR BRINGING AWARENESS
IS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THE HEALTH DISPARITIES ARE
GLARING AS WE'VE HEARD OUR CLICK
DISADVANTAGE EXPERIENCE POOR
HEALTH CARE ACCESS IN A LOWER
QUALITY OF CARE.
AT THE LEGISLATIVE BODY WE
SHOULD WE NEED TO MAKE THE
BROUGHT COMMITMENT TO
ELIMINATING THE DISPARITIES THAT
EXIST.
THE UNITED STATES HEALTH CARE
TODAY OR FIRST WE MUST ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE DISPARITIES
EXIST AND AGREE THAT IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE FOR ANYONE TO
EXPERIENCE. FOR HEALTHCARE
OUTCOMES BASED SOLELY ON RACE
AND ECONOMIC STATICS WE ALSO
NEED TO ENCOURAGE MORE
CALIFORNIA'S TO NOT ONLY BECOME
INFORMED AND LEARN THEIR STATUS
WILL ALSO DISCUSS HOW WE CAN
PREVENT HIV.
I STRONGLY ASCARI VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD THING
NO FOR CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION --
I THINK MY GOOD FRIENDS FROM LOS
ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO FOR
RAISING THIS ISSUE AS A MEDICAL
STUDENT I REMEMBER THAT WAS
ABOUT THE TIME WHEN HIV STARTED
TAKE OFF AN I REMEMBERED THE
FEAR.
THAT REALLY STRUCK AND IN THE
COMMUNITY ABOUT THE HIV AND OF
COURSE THAT FEAR ALSO
UNFORTUNATELY DISPLAYED ITSELF
AS DISCRIMINATION --
DISPLAYED ITSELF.
IN IN MANY WAYS --
THAT ARE VERY HARMFUL NOW HIV IS
NOW MORE A CHRONIC CONDITION --
DOES MEAN WE'D TACK WE CAN CURE
ITS CHRONIC CONDITION WEEK
PREVENTED.
BUT WHILE SCIENCE IS CERTAINLY
GIVEN THIS ITS OPPORTUNITIES
SOCIETY HAS NOT EVOLVED QUITE AS
QUICKLY AND WE STILL HAVE
TREMENDOUS DISPARITIES.
SO EVEN THOUGH HIV MAY NOT BE
QUITE ON THE HEADLINES AS MUCH
AS IT DID WHEN IT FIRST BROKE
OUT.
THERE STILL MUCH WORK TO DO AND
WE NEED TO RAISE OUR AWARENESS
AND I THINK THE AUTHOR SPRINGS
RESOLUTION FORD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM MEMBERS
SEE NO FURTHER SENATOR HUESO.
HELLO ANYONE THERE.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM UM.
I JUST WANTED --
TO TRY MINUTES SUPPORT THIS BILL
BUT ALSO --
BRING UP AN ISSUE.
THAT IS PREVALENT IN MY DISTRICT
AND AND LAST YEAR I RAN A BILL --
DIRECTING THE TE OFFICE OF BI
NATIONAL BORDER HEALTH. TO
ALLOCATE MORE RESOURCES OR COME
UP WITH A PLAN.
IN THE IN THE BORDER AREA TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE HEALTH.
ISSUES THAT EXIST THERE AND WE
FOUND THROUGH SOME OF OUR
HEARINGS.
THAT THAT THERE IS ARE GROWING
EPIDEMIC ALONG THE BORDER --
AROUND AIDS AND HIV.
AND HOW --
IN MANY CASES IT'S SPREADING
BECAUSE OR THE REASON IN
AWARENESS THERE AS WELL.
AND THIS THIS ISSUE IS ONE THAT
TRANCE TRANSCENDS THE THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
AND IT'S A BIG ISSUE IN MY
DISTRICT OUT THERE IMPERIAL
COUNTY AND ALSO.
IN SOUTHERN SENEGAL COUNTY AND
AND AND IT'S BEEN A BIG PROBLEM.
AND AND MATTER BUDGET CHAIR I I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE AND AND AND I WOULD LIKE --
TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN DO MORE
IN THE STATE TO BRING AWARENESS
AND AND REALLY GET PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A REAL
THREAT OUT THERE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND IN SOME AREAS WHERE WE HAVE
A LACK OF OF RESOURCES TO BUILD
AWARENESS AND EDUCATION WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING HERE IN THE
STATE.
AND I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR FOR SHINING LIGHT ON THIS
ISSUE AND I LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU THIS YEAR ON THIS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO SEEN NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER MAJORITY LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES --
FOR THEIR TIMELY ASTUTE COMMENTS --
WE IN MANY AREAS OF THE STATE
ARE FACING A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS ACROSS THE BOARD.
THE S. T. I. RATES ARE IN ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES WOULD SHOCK YOU
ABSOLUTELY SHOCK YOU.
AND WE'VE NOT EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN MANY
OF THESE AREAS.
AGAIN AS WE TALKED ABOUT ON THE
HISTORY WITH REGARD TO HIV AIDS
AND HOW IT IMPACTED MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE NOT KEPT UP
AROUND INVESTMENTS.
IN TERMS OF HOW IT IS NOW
IMPACTING OF COMMUNITIES WHAT
WOMEN -- AND
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
TALKED ABOUT YET A NOTHER
COMMUNITY ON THAT'S BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY A
VIRUS ON THAT FORTY YEARS LATER
NOW WE SHOULD ALL HAVE A BETTER
IDEA IN TERMS OF HOW TO PREVENT.
HOW TO TREAT WITHOUT BIAS AND SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE ON GOING
CONVERSATION AND TALKING ABOUT
HOW FUNDING REALLY MUST FOLLOW
THE NEWLY IMPACTED POPULATIONS
AND OUR BROADER CONVERSATIONS
AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH?
AND S. T. EYES ACROSS THE BOARD
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE ON SR.
FIFTEEN THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL MISS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I FELL [inaudible]
I GORGEOUS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I OSEM [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TOTEM [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I REQUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I ROOM [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ILIKE HUSKY.
AYE WIENER.
AYE WILK.
AYE.
STEP STONE A STONE I I WAS
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
[inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
AT THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT ARE I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE --
TWO GUESTS WHO ARE WITH US TODAY --
WHO ARE LEADERS IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST --
HIV --
INCLUDING OUR FIGHT AGAINST --
IT'S A V. AIDS ARE WITHIN THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY --
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING --
ALEXIS DALY WHO IS THE HEALTH
EDUCATOR AND STI TESTING
COORDINATOR AT THE SACRAMENTO
LGBTQ COMMUNITY CENTER --
AND RAINY --
COPELAND'S WHO'S THE PRESIDENT
AND SO.
TO WELCOME HERE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE
BEFORE US IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS MADAM PRO TEM.
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
OF I WANNA.
REMIND EVERYONE THAT ON TUESDAY
AT ELEVEN AM THERE IS THE STATE
OF THE STATE.
BY OUR GOVERNOR IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SO WE WILL OF COURSE AS
A SENATE WANT TO BE ON TIME --
SO I WOULD REMIND YOU NOW AND
HOPEFULLY WE WILL --
BE ABLE TO GO OVER AND ENJOY THE
STATE OF THE STATE TOGETHER.
ON TUESDAY BUT OUT WE WILL --
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME --
AS MADAME PRESIDENT WILL AGAIN
REPEAT BECAUSE THAT IS HER DUTY --
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE BUT WE WILL RECONVENE ON
WEEKEND.
THANK YOU CENTER ATKINS SENATOR
MITCHELL FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU
RISE PURPOSES OF ANNOUNCEMENT
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE AT NINE
FORTY FIVE NINE FORTY FIVE
COLLEAGUES I WILL GAVEL DOWN.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
GERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE WE
WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND MEMBERS